お願いします 今日は人とどのように付き合いますか？というテーマで
大体回ぐらい分けてお話をしたいと思っています
うーん 今まで仏教の話は日本で始めた時は
できるだけ具体的に日常生活の中の例を出しながら話してきたんです
なぜならば 釈尊の教えっていうのは日本ではなかった概念であって
仏教のような言葉がありましたけど
意味は全く違うもので
本当に馴染みのない話でしたから
で あまりにも仏教っていうのは具体的で合理的で
科学的で みんな聞きたくないっていうかね
まあそういうことはありましたね
初めは 宗教っていうのは神秘的で形而上学的で
科学とは関係ない もう何でもありき世界ような感じが普通
世の中どこでもあるんですね
超能力とか神通力の話とか
で まあいわゆるわかりやすく言えば
我々の希望を叶ってくれる
欲望を叶ってくれる世界
叶ってくれるということはおかしいんだけど
実際には叶ってくれませんだけど
ただ何かになりたいと欲望だけはあるんですね
その欲望は実際の社会では叶ってくれません
大金持ちになりたいとかね
世界一美しい人になりたいとか思ったっても
実際の世界ではそんなことにはなれないし
で がん治してほしいとかね
でも人間っていうのはそういういろいろ欲望希望がありまして
宗教ではそんなことは何でもやってあげますよというふうな
このもう全く非科学的なことばっかしで
で そういうことにあまりにもなじみて馴染んでしまって
しっかりと生きる道を教えると
なんかみんな嫌な顔をしたんですから
最初はいろいろ具体的な例を申し上げながら喋ってきたんです
一旦わかってきたところで
まあ論理的に仏教というものは理解しなくちゃいけない
単なる例だけ聞いても
それは役に立たないんですね
ですから 論理的に いわゆる仏教の方程式ですか
まあそれをわかってしまえば
自分たちでちゃんと何のことなくちゃんと生きていられるんですね
で そういうふうに私は話の内容を徐々に変えていっちゃうんだけど
具体的な例を喋ってた時は
そんな具体的なことを言ったら
私たちはしっかりと仏教は何ですかと知りたいんだと
もう反論されちゃったんですね
僕の頭の中ではもうちょっと早いんじゃないかなと
で たとえ四聖諦の話であろうが
浄土の話であろうと もうちょっと早いんじゃないかと
という気持ちだったんだけど
で それ話してて まあそろそろいいんじゃないかなと思って
論理的な世界に説明しようと思うと
いえ 具体的に話しなさいって
どっちにすればいいかと私はわかりませんだけど
まあ人間というのはそんなもんなんですよ
これはこれだったら いえ
違いますよ 違うと言うんですね
ですから もうとんでもないんで
付き合いは付き合いしにくいんです
で 簡単に喋ったら ああ
面白くない 簡単すぎやと
まあじゃあそれだったら一応しっかり喋りますっていうのは
そんな難しいこと言ったってわかるわけじゃないでしょうと
短く喋っちゃったら そんななんで短く喋るんですか？と
じゃあわかりやすく説明して喋りますよ
そんな延々喋ったの 我々は忙しいんだと
だからまあ その上 うまく人間と付き合う方法も教えてくれと
まあわかりやすいのはこれぐらいなんですよ
講演は これが全部なんです
で やってみろと できるわけないと思いますよ
人間と付き合うということは
こんな状態だったらね
ですから 私はそういう風にずっと
自分が個人的にやられて生きて
で 何をしてもそれはそれは違いますよという状態で
で ということは 皆様も同じひどい経験あって生きているということなんです
私だけではなくて ああ
よかったという経験はなかなかないだろうと思いますよ
ですから 世の中で付き合いしにくい存在といえば人間だけなんです
それまず覚えておいてください
社会性は全くなし それからまあ
日本でよく人気のある言葉というのは和ですか
それは人間はもう夢の中でも知ってることじゃないんです
あれは全く完璧な嘘で
誰一人も和は知らないんです
で そういうのは人間の中ではない
日本でもない 和っていうのは日本の言葉なんですけど
それは日本の言葉なんですけど
日本の社会にもなし 他の国々でもなしと
社会性はなし でも社会動物っていうのは
人間だと偉そうな哲学者が社会学者が定義するんです
人間というのは社会的な動物だよと
何言うんですかとか ハチミツ
ミツバチとか見たらちゃんとした社会動物なんですけど
人間は何でしょうかとね
俺が俺がとかね 我々とかね
そういうことでばっかり生きてるんだけど
ミツバチを見てください
俺も女王になりてやりたい
俺も女王になりてやりたいと思っているミツバチ
ミツバチがいませんだからみんなメスでしょうに
あのオス以外はね まあオス以外はメスしかいませんだけど
で ミツバチの中でまあほんの少ない数がオスで
他のみんなメスなんですよ
あのローヤルゼリー食べさせればみんな大きくなって
女王っていうかね 女王蜂になるんですよ
でもうまく社会一つとして一体としてちゃんとやってるんです
選挙は一度も聞いたことがないんです
僕はこのミツバチの中で女王を選ぶ選挙とかね
仕事を選ぶ選挙とか 何もない
ただ 何のことなく自分自分の仕事をする
幼虫の世話をする蜂はそれはする
蜜を運ぶ蜂はそれをやる
蜂の巣の中に空気を 何て言いますか
換気扇ですか それ 空気を循環する人々は
それはちゃんとやる 守る
ガードをやってる みんなそれぞれ自分たちの仕事をする
で そこでハチミツもいっぱいあるんだけど
私はいっぱい食べてやるとかね
そういうことは一人もないんです
ですから そこ見張り役もいりませんし
見張り役必要なのは敵が来たらどうしようかということだけ
ああいうのは本当の社会生活なんですね
人間にはそんなものは全くないんです
ですから まあ私 きつい言葉で言った方が分かりやすいんで
別に私は腹が立ってるわけでも何でもないんです
一応 強烈にきつく言った方が
まあ頭に何とか残るだろうと思います
ただ それだけのことで
ちょっときつく言うんです
そう 親切に言っちゃえば何一つも残らないんですね
ですから 普通は我々出家の人々はもうもう徹底的に敬語を使って大変礼儀正しく喋らなくちゃいけない
それはもう仏教ではもう厳しく決まってるんです
で 私はそれは全部破って
もう全く違う もうできるだけ強烈にきつく喋ろうと
で その方が分かりやすいでは分かりやすいんです
そういうことで もう一番この社会性がない
こう言っちゃったら こう言えばああいうというふうな状態っていうのは人間の生き方なんですね
で それで問題が起こるということもまた当たり前のことで
自然の問題以外 動物の世界では問題は作らないんです
平和なんです 戦っている動物でも
それは戦うことは自分の仕事であって
別にそれ以上何もないんです
オス同士戦うでしょうに
それは戦わなくちゃいけない
ただそれだけ 別に向こうに対して何か怒りとか何か持っているわけじゃないんです
平和的なんですね 人間の社会だけはそういうこと何もなく
なんの意味もなく戦ったり
相手を倒したりして 大変苦しい世界を作ったりして
問題いっぱい作っているんです
動物の世界で問題があったならば
それは自然破壊になったところで
みんな殲滅になるとか
それぐらいのものなんですね
我々の社会では自然と関係なく
いくら贅沢な生活をしても
もう戦いの世界 苦しみの世界は終わらないんです
そういうことで まず理解するポイントは
人間は一番付き合いしにくい
性格を持っていること
それから出てくるのは
我々は人間と付き合って
いろんなストレスが溜まったりして
腹が立ったりして 悔やんだり
悩んだりしたりする ありとあらゆる苦悩を味わっているということは
決して珍しい稀な経験ではありません
ということ 人と付き合うことによって苦しみが生まれなかったならば
苦悩を味わうことはなかったならば
喧嘩にならなかったならば
腹が立たなかったならば
どこかでおかしいんです
ただそれだけ 普通の付き合いっていうのは
いつでもそういうことばっかりなんです
じゃあそれだったら それは社会と付き合う時だよと
私は家族だったら大変仲良くしているんだよと
という人がいるかもしれません
それまた正真正銘の嘘で
家族の中でいっぱい喧嘩するんです
一番わがままを言うのは家族の中なんです
自分本位で言おうとするの
ですから 家族っていうのは単なる戦場であって何もないんです
社会も同じこと みんな誤解しているんですよ
この問題は社会で起こるんだと
家族は大丈夫だと そうじゃないんです
社会でも同じく 家族の中でも同じく
ありとあらゆる葛藤やら苦しみやら悩むことやら生まれるんです
生まれなきゃおかしいんだと
それだけ理解しておきましょう
人間付き合いがうまくいったと言えばおかしくて
人間付き合いでいろいろ葛藤があるんだというのは自然だと
どこを探しても見つかりませんよ
たまにもう日本ではいろいろもういられませんと
ちょっとお金があったり
外国語を喋ったりする方々がいて
外国文化に触れたりして
外国に行ったところで大変気持ちが良かったとか
国が大きくて 物は物価が安くて
人が優しくて で 日本はもうみんな時間に追われてもう生きづらいんだと言って
外国に住んでしまおう
住みましょうと思って行く人々いるんだけどね
それももう何と言いますか
もう甘い話で そこへ行ったら
そこにまたありとあらゆる問題が生まれてくるんです
例えば ある時期 日本の方々はハワイの土地を買い始めたんですね
向こうはいいやと 楽で
もう何の問題もなくとか
どうなったんですか？向こうに嫌われちゃったんですね
買うな 来るなと それでハワイのなんとかなんとか政府ですか
まあアメリカですけど
その州の方がもうもう日本人は土地は全部もう買ってしまっちゃったら
我々どうなるんだ それなんとかしなきゃと
そこまで話が出てきたんだから
そこで向こうに嫌われてこっち来るなって言われる
言われるのに 強引にお金で
お金の力で建物を買って住んでいたっても
トラブルを起こさないと思いますか
起こせますよ それ誤解なんですよ
たまたま旅行の旅行に行ったと
で  1週間旅行すると もうお客さんだから
まあ本当の顔を見せませんでしょうし
1週間で帰るんだから
もう誰でもできるだけ親切にしてあげる
あれぐらいのことを理解しないのは何でしょうかね
皆様もそうでしょうね
自分の家にお客さんが来たら 1
日泊まりますよって言っちゃったら
一生懸命面倒見るでしょうに
すごい豪華な料理を作ってあげたりとか
じゃああなた方の料理はすごくうまいし
豪華でもあるし で じゃあ私はこの家に住みましょうと言っちゃったらどうなるんですか
そこは事実でしょうに
それは外国に行ったって同じことなんだ
1週間ぐらいだったらよく親切にしてくれるんですよ
例えばアフリカみたいにね
まあ自然だけある国に行ったっても
みんな自然の中だから
人を見ても行って来てくださいと言いますよ
ああ こんなに自然に溶け込まれて生きることは素晴らしいんではないかといって
日本人がそこに住むと
住んだ途端 その日本人が自分だけの日本文化の箱を作っちゃうでしょ
それすごい異物で エイリアンみたいで
それからやられちゃうんです
いくら親切な黒人であろうとも
黒人というのはすごい
まあ一般的にも親切な人々なんですけど
大変な人が仲が良くなっちゃうし
でも ああいうふうに なんかちょっと異物的な
エイリアン的な存在になっちゃったら
もうやりきれなくなっちゃうんです
ですから このどこへ逃げたっても
人と付き合うということはもうかなり難しい
すごいきついんです ですから
その人とうまく付き合う方法
これから話そうと努力はしますけど
で 私は一つ二つ今まだ悩んでるんです
論理的に厳密に方程式だけ言っておきましょうか
まあ大雑把に具体的な例を一つ一つ言っておきましょうかと
論理的なことを喋ったら
皆様それを丸暗記でして覚えれば一生役に立つんです
立つんです その時その時使用できます
でもすごいきつい話になっちゃう
難しくなるんです で あっちこっちいろいろ具体的な例を喋ると
聞いてるとこ気持ちいい
それで終わり 具体的な例だから
同じ例は二度と起こりませんだから
ある子供とあるお母さんがこうやって付き合うべきですよと僕は言ったっても
そういうケースはまた二度と起こりませんだからもうそれっきりで役に立たない
その場では気持ちどっちにするか私はまだまだ決まってないんだ
そのうち決まります で
じゃああのテーマに入りますけど
人と付き合うのはなぜそんなに難しいかと
だから今まで言ったのは
これ難しいと 世の中で一番きついことだと
まず私は言いました それは皆様理解してほしい
もし嘘だと思うならば
人と付き合うのは大変簡単だと思うならば
どうぞ今のうち自分の意見を述べてください
そうでないと皆様は同じ経験だと思って仮定して話を進めます
一応普通の経験で言えば
それはそんな簡単なものじゃないんです
もし反論があるなら 反論的な心
気持ちさえあるならば
もう一度それを言います
戻って 自分言うことが完全に自分何かやりたいとかあったあったとする
それに完全に自分の母親
父親納得してもらった覚えがありますか
私たちにとっては 世の中で一番我々のことを心配してくれる
一番心に近い 我々がどんな悪いことをしたっても許してくれる存在は両親なんです
何の恥もなく 何でも言える
頼られる いわゆる心のつながりがものすごい強いんです
そういう自分の父親 母親を説得することはできます
子供に 僕にはできないかもしれませんだけど
あ 私のお父さんだから
まあ何のことない まあ言ったらちゃんとやってくれますよという
そういう経験があるならば
どうぞ正直に言ってください
私の知識で言うならば
自分の父親さえ母親さえ
自分何かやりたければ
それに説得させること
納得させることって至難の業なんです
ものすごい難しいんです
喧嘩して家出しなくちゃいけないんです
自分何かやりたければ
それで成功するならば
どうせ母親ある父親だから
喧嘩して出て行ったっても
なんとかあの子は無事で幸福でありますようにって気持ちはありますけど
それなのにそういう状態でしょうに
結婚して孫が生まれても
うちに口利かない両親がいるんじゃないんですか
ですから 自分の両親とも人間関係は難しい
やりにくい まあ他人のことはまあ言うまでもないと
ですから 難しいという立場で話さなくちゃいけない
いわゆる不可能という立場から喋りましょう
人と人が付き合うのは不可能であると
うまく それはなぜかと
今も皆さんはわかっているかもしれません
僕は前に言いましたから
不思議なこと 人間はものすごいわがままなんです
わがまま 人間は自分だけ良ければよろしいという
気持ちで生きているんです
人間が自分個人の自分のこの幸福を目指して生きているんです
それでどうなってますけど
心のエネルギーは自分の中に入ってるんです
自分という殻を作って
その中で 例えば円で描くならば
例えば 個っていうのはこういう風な生命だと思うと
エネルギーは全部中に入ってるんですね
外と関係ないんです 自分のことしか考えてないんです
そこからなんですね 問題が生まれてくるのは
それで 何のために我々はその自分の内しか考えない人が
何のために他人と付き合いたがるんですかね
他人と付き合いたがるのは
自分の利益のためなんです
我々は他人と付き合いたがるのは
そのこの利益のためなんです
損するために人と付き合う人がいませんでしょ
怪我するために殺されるとも
殺されていただくために人と付き合う人がいますか？いません
自分の利益のために 幸福のために人と付き合いたがります
そうするとどうなるかというと
付き合いたがる人が 相手がまたわがままで
自分のことしか考えない人で
その人とこの人がその人と付き合っちゃうと
その人が損しちゃうんです
相手が 損しちゃうとこれ付き合ってはいけないんですね
で 自分に損をする人が
私は私のことは考えているんです
そこである人と付き合うと
私はいろいろ損をする
そうすると私の幸福を破る敵なんです
なんとなくちょっと論理的になりましたけど
個人個が個人が人と付き合おうとすると
その付き合いたがる人が敵になっちゃうんです
その瞬間で そこで人付き合いっていうのは成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
すごい厳密な論理なんです
で もう一人のこう書いても同じく中に中に入ってるエネルギーを持ってるんですね
ですから こちらにいる人がこちらから何もエネルギーで考えましょう
何もエネルギーを得られないんです
エネルギーは中に入ってるんだから
そこでこの人はこの人と付き合いたい
そこでこの人はこの人からエネルギーを奪わなくちゃいけないんですね
だから付き合うんだからです
そうすると この人はこの人の敵に簡単になっちゃうんです
数学で考えたってもいいんです
例えば  1万円欲しがってる人がいるんだと
そこである人に会って
あの人から 1万円奪おうと思っちゃうと
思って付き合ってみたら
その人は 2万円奪おうと思って私と付き合ってるんだったら
敵同士でしょうに うまくいくわけじゃないんです
もし私は 1万円が欲しくて人からもらおうと思ったら
もしお金あって誰かいるならば 1万円あげたいなと思っている人がいる
そこで私が言って 1万円くださいませと言ったら
ああ ちょうどよかったと
私もこれあげようと 誰かあげようかなと探していたところで
ちょうどよかったと気持ちよくくれるんです
そうすると人間関係はうまくいっちゃうんです
私は人から 1万円奪おうとすると
その人は私から 2万円奪わせちゃうと
お互いに何のことなく敵同士なんです
そうすると人間付き合いどうやってしますか？というと
私は自分 1万円マイナスなんですけど
持っているものはあの人に奪われないように
いわゆる 2万円を奪われないように気をつけなくちゃいけない
向こう側も私も 1万円を奪わないようにと気をつけなくちゃいけない
だから敵同士なんです
そういう数字で考えると理解しやすいと思います
わがままだから 我々が生まれつきわがままの私が自分のために人と付き合おうとすると
その人 その人 敵になってしまっちゃう
みんな自分の心をきつく鍵をかけて固くする
それでものすごい敵同士の付き合いになっちゃうんです
それは人間の付き合い方なんです
何のこと？何もできないんです
一般社会論では 社会学的な知識では
そっちには解決は絶対見つかり
ない 心理学者であろうが
どんなカウンセラーであろうが
どんな学校の先生であろう 「
うまくこうやってやってください」と 「
うまくいきますよ」と
そんなことは全くありえないんです
この基本的なことを直すことは誰にもできませんだから
たとえ我々は人と付き合う方法を教えたっても
それは私のわがままをどうやって他人から満たしてくれるかという方法だから
それはありえない話なんです
ですから そういうきつい条件の中で人間がお互いに付き合ってるんです
じゃあその中でも まあ一応我々は人々と話をしたり
もういろんな付き合いはしています
やっぱりよくわかりやすいでしょうね
それはいつでもお互いの利害関係というか
お互いに助け合うということによって成り立っているんです
私は人から何かを求める
その人は私から何かを求める
そうすると その求める立場で仲がうまくいくんです
それは完全たる人付き合いじゃないんです
じゃあ わかりやすい例を申し上げると
若い男 若い男のが男の人がいると
で その人は自分の 欲望を満たすために欲望があって燃えているんだと
それはもうなかなかきつくて
何とかしてその火を 消してくれる人がいませんかと思ったところで
若い女性が見つかる そうすると
もしその女性もやっぱり男性誰かいた方がいいやと思っていたならば
ちょうどうまい具合にお互いに仲良くなっちゃうんです
それは完全たる二人が一緒になったわけじゃないんです
それぞれの向こうは何かこちらから求めて
こちらは向こう側が何か求めていて
それでなんとか繋がりが生まれるのです
その二人がやがて結婚したっても
二人は別々で なぜならば
奥さんが他のところで旦那さんの悪口を言うんだから
で 旦那さんは旦那さんで別な世界を作っているんだから
別の仲間を作って 友達が作って
飲み友達が作ったりして遊んでいるんだから
完全にお互いに繋げたわけじゃないんです
繋がりません 完全には
そこで我々 ある人がある人と仲良くしたいんだと
友達になりたいんだと
でも その人から見れば
私から何も得るものがないんだと思っちゃったら
もう迷惑な顔をして振り向いてくれませんでしょ
ですから 現在我々の人付き合いの場合は
そういう何かの条件の中でお互いにこの助け合うやりとり
ギブアンドテイクの状態が出来上がったら
人付き合いというものは出来上がるんです
ですから それが社会に皆様知ってる人の付き合いなんです
そうすると このギブアンドテイク状態が破れちゃったら
お互いにまた敵同士になっちゃうんです
たとえ 20年結婚生活をしても
もし旦那さんが浮気でもしたら
奥さんが腹が立って離婚
離婚しますよって言っちゃいますから
その信頼関係を失ったら
あなたを信頼していましたと
それで切れちゃうんですね
それぐらいの弱い人間関係なんですね
自分が育てた子供であろうとも
子供が親から得をする場合は親と一緒にいるんです
仲良くしてくれる それである日になってくると
親から得るものは終わっちゃうんですね
終わったら親は敵に回してもう帰っちゃうんです
出て行っちゃう そういうふうな人間関係っていうのはできているんです
ですから まあそんなもんだかなと思って
もう寂しく生きるしか方法ないと
人とは付き合うことはできないんだと
徹底的な孤独主義で その時その時ほどほどに付き合って寂しく生きているか
笑い あるいはまあ何か釈尊の知恵でも借りて
何か違う方法を見つかるかという
ことなんです はい じゃああのと
一応論理的にもうちょっと申し訳ありますけど
じゃあお釈迦様の教えから言えば
どういう付き合いすればいいかと
一番大事なのは まあまずその私はわがままである
それは正直に認める 嘘を言わないこと
この嘘の戒律は一人の人間というのも守らないんです
口では人に何か言葉では嘘を言わないんだけど
生き方そのものは嘘だけ
嘘だけの塊なんです どうしようもないんです
だから真理がわからなくなっちゃうんです
例えば 今私が言っているこのわがまま
人間はわがままですよという言葉さえあまり聞きたくないでしょ
我々は神の子であると
尊い魂を持っている 尊い素晴らしい仏様の子供たちですよとか
なんとか言ったら気持ちいいでしょ
皆様は体だけではなくて
心も美しく輝いてますよと
まあいくらでも言えますよ
僕にも言葉の遊びだったら
人を嘘で褒めろうと思ったら
まあ私も結構上手だと思いますけど
本当に嫌な人だったら褒めるんです
自分で心配している人は褒めません
全然心配しているんだから
そんな褒めて もう何て言いますか
人を落とし穴に入れてはいけませんと
まあどうしてももう邪魔で嫌で
もう迷惑だったらもう褒めてあげる
でまあ褒められて まあすごい落とし穴に落ちますけど
まあそれはそれで とにかく我々一般的に言えば
そういう風に皆様のもう体だけじゃなくて
心も素晴らしく綺麗ですねとか言ったらすぐ気持ちよくなる
皆様 美しい清らかな精神
心 魂を持ってるんだと
仏心菩提心持ってるんだと
仏様の子供ですよと言ったら
誰でもああそうですか
気持ちいい話ですねとか
素晴らしい教えですよとか
なんかくだらないことを言うんです
そこに何が嘘かというと
我々は自分がわがままであることは認めたくない
嘘つきたいんです ですから
ああいう風に言われると気持ちよくなるんです
みんな醜いわがままですよと言われたら気持ち悪くなるんです
だからまあどっちでも構いませんだけど
一応中道的な立場で 我々はもうそんなにそんな難しいことではなくて
まあ所詮生命っていうのは自己愛があってわがままで
自分のことを自分の幸福
自分の利益を考えて生きているんだと
それは第1番目に理解する
第2番目に私だけじゃなくてもうちょっと合理的になりまして
自分の子供も友達ももう旦那も奥さんも
会社の同僚みんなも 社会も
人は誰であろうとわがままであると
自分のことしか考えないものだと
と理解する その理解によって大体結構うまくいくんです
理解しておけば そうすると腹が立たないんです
よく僕の耳に聞こえる話なんですけど
人々はお互いに話し合ったりして喧嘩すると
あんた随分わがままですねとか言われるんですね
その時は言ってる人もすごく怒っているし
言われる側はさらに怒るんです
またむちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃなことを言うんですね
それよく耳に入るんです
その話が あなたは随分わがままですねということは
相手を非難するために言うんじゃないんです
そう言われたら相手を非難したことになっちゃうんです
それは当たり前で 今も喧嘩になっているのは
その人は自分のことで喧嘩しているんだから
それを理解すれば なるほど
その人の立場から見れば
私はこういうこういうふうに
ああ間違ったんだと それを理解できるんです
そうすると喧嘩にならないで
何かなるんです あなたは随分わがままですよね
言ったっても 言ってる人は何ですかね
言ってる人も随分わがままで
だから喧嘩になってるんだから
ですから 人は誰であろうとわがままであるということは理解する
理解してからどうなるんですか？ 3番目に
3番目にこういうこと
これが大事なポイント
何があろうとも驚かないと
何があろうとも驚かない
それはきちんと覚えておいてください
我々人間関係 そういう驚いて壊しちゃうんです
例えば自分の子供は素晴らしいんだとえらい勘違いしていて
そこで万引きして見つかったと
認めたくないんですね
我が子に限ってはそんなことは絶対ありえないんだと
よくも美しい服を着て
女性であんな醜いことを聞きにくいことを口から出しちゃうんですね
本当にお母さんたちっていうのは
この頭が悪くてもうもうすごい
もう頭悪いっていうのはそういうことでね
子供のことで全く嫌な存在になってしまっちゃうんです
ですから このそういう驚いちゃうんですね
私の子に限ってはと たとえ自分の旦那さんがどうかいうて浮気したんだと話聞いたってても
ショック受けちゃって
ヒステリー起こしちゃって
なんであんな驚くんですかね
それその論理をわかってないんだからなんです
ですから  3番目に言ったこと
何があろうとも驚かない
なぜならば何でもあり得るんです
この世の中で 生命 その個が
その個々ごとに自分の幸福を考えているんだから
ですから 男っていうのは
自分の奥さんにものすごい忠実で
一生で命かけてますよと言っても
本人知らないんですよ
この地球でどこか歩く回っちゃう時で歩く回ってると
なんとなく自分に気に入ってる人とかね
目に焼き付く可能性はあるんです
あるいは向こう側からいろいろ工夫して誘惑されるということもありますし
そこで奥さんの前で誓いしたっても
私はもうあなたにあなたに忠実でいて
それを破っちゃったら地獄に落ちますよとか何とか
それぐらいの誓い誓いしたっても
そんな約束はもう通用しないんですよ
どうなるか 自分の心はどうなるか分かったもんじゃないんです
すぐ自分の利益あるなと思ったら
そこへもう変化するという恐れがあります
ですから 人とうまく付き合いたければ
何があろうとも驚くまへんと
そうするとうまく付き合うことはできるんです
それは驚く人々は全く無知なんです
いろんな我々社会を見ていると
毎日いろんな問題が出てくるでしょ
そうするとまずオレンジ共済という問題があったりして
国会議員でしょうに で
最近この一番野村證券ですか
まあ問題があったり それから今なんとか保険ですかであったりとか
毎日なんですね そんなことは
政治家が汚職するわ もう宗教家が人殺すわ
もう人だますわ それでみんな毎日驚きっぱなしで
ああ驚いた 驚いたと やりきれないんです
それからまた次の人を信頼する
ある政治家が汚職したんだと聞いちゃったら
まあ次の人を選んで その人を信頼する
で その人なんとかしてったらまた驚いちゃって
じゃあ次の人選びます
この人こそやと そんなことは世の中であり得ないんです
この驚くのはいいんだけど
がっかりするでしょ がっかりしましたと
ある宗教が人殺しやっちゃったら
まあ僕らにまでいろんなことを言われるし
それまた言われてまたやっちゃう
やるんです 同じこと ですから
何があろうとも驚かない
それはもう人と付き合うためにはもう抜群の
手段なんです クールで
あ そうと で 例えばもう一番悪い例で考えましょう
自分の親戚か旦那さんか子供が殺人をしたんだと
もう対応できないでしょ
そのショックで 自分でも自殺したくなっちゃうんですね
ああ 嫌だと あれ 何ですかと
あれ あまりにも驚きすぎて
もう何もできなくなっちゃうんですね
今まで大変いい子でいた自分の子供であろうか
何一つ微かな悪いこともしなかったかもしれませんだけど
なんかどうか殺人を犯しちゃったと
ったらもう何のことなくそう驚く
驚かない時は子供 まあどういうことかな
聞いたらそれ全部説明してくれるし
それでそういう場合はこういうこういう風にすればいいんじゃないかなと
知恵も生まれてくるんです
もし殺人を犯した子供がお母さん面会に来たっても
顔を合わせたくないんですね
なぜならば 泣いたり喚いたり
ヒステリー起こしたり
私はそんな風にお前を育てたことはない
なんでそんなこと そんな感じで喋るんだから
ですから 子供に自分の立場を言えなくなっちゃうんですね
驚かない場合は何のことなく
お互いの心は通じ合う
通じ合うだけじゃない
対策方法 問題が起きたらどうするべきかと
それも何のことなく出てくる
そういう風に人付き合いの場合は
もうこれは一番必要な
もうこれ一つでできるんです
何があろうとも驚かないということ
なぜならば 何度 でもあり得るんだと
女で生まれ 男で生まれる男の人々
女になっちゃう世界だから
今最近 あれまあ医学的に不可能なのに
医学的に不可能なのにこうなっちゃいますね
あれ 驚くんですか？私は驚きませんよ
あ なるほど あの子の気持ちだなと
女女になりたがっているんだと
それだけのことでしょうに
もし私の親切な誰か人だったら
僕は助けてあげますよ
いろいろ相談してあげたりとかね
どうするべきがいいかとかね
これのあの得と損 あなたこうやったら何を損しますか？何を得しますかとかね
で 仲良く相談してあげますけどね
まあそういう人は今までなかったんだけど
一応 まああったならば僕は驚かない
そこで親が母親がショックを受けちゃうんだと
別に自分の子供だから別に驚かない場合は
その何かディスカッションですか
話し合うということはできるんですね
話し合うことによって
誰両者にもいい結果が出てくるんです
そういうことで 我々は人付き合いの場合は
何があろうとも驚かないという論理で
生きていくように努力してみましょう
確実に負け込むんです
で 子供小さい子供を面倒見る時でもね
ちょっと何か間違いを起こしちゃったら
お母さんがまあキャーキャーといちいち言っちゃうでしょうに
だからまあ女性のこの体っていうのはすごい
ものすごい強いでしょ
あれでよかった あれほど失態を起こしちゃったら
男っていうのはもう二十歳になって死んでしまっちゃいます
よくもね  24時間一人だけで生きてるんだから
だからもう自然の不思議さというのは
まあそれぐらい女性にはこの生命力ですか
生命力は過ぎてるんですけど
ですから 例えば自分の子供の場合も
何かしたら ああ またやったんですか？とか
なんでそんなことをするんですかとか
すぐもう驚いてるんですね
失態を起こしてるんですね
そこで間違いを起こした子供は嫌なんですね
たとえ自分が間違いを起こしても
ああいう風に言われるのは嫌なんです
なんでそんなことをするんですか？と本人もわかってるんだから
この世の中で自分を忘れてみんな考えてるんだからね
真理わからないだけで
この世の中で じゃあこれから
これから悪いことをしよう
これから失敗しようと思って行動する人がいます
じゃあ奥様方 考えてください
今日の料理は失敗しますと
そういう風に料理した経験あります？ないでしょう
ある ないでしょう だから人間っていうのは
今日の料理は美味しく作りますよという気持ちでやる
その過程で失敗するんであって
別に自分のせいじゃないでしょうに
だから本人知ってます
あ 今日はちょっと失敗だと
焼きすぎだと 煮すぎだと
塩加減はちょっと今日はまずかったとか
味付けはちょっとまずかったと本人も知ってるんですね
それで旦那さんが今日はまずいなと言われると腹が立つんじゃないんですか
自分の腹が立つんだけど
子供に平気で同じこと言うんです
何か間違いを起こしちゃったら
ですから このうまく人と付き合う場合は
あの こういうことを考えてほしいんですね
人は 誰でも失敗しますと
今度はと思って行動はしない
誰で 行動する過程で成功か失敗かっていうのは
それは別な話で これ別な角度での価値判断なんですね
自分が真面目にやりたいんです
結果としてどうであろうと
それで結果として失敗だと思ったら
我々は腹が立つんじゃなくて
ああ 別に驚かないんだからね
まあそんなことはまあどうせあり得ることだから
ああそう 失敗したの それだけのことなんですね
子供だと失敗しちゃったの
その一言葉で全部直るんです
本人はけなしたわけでもないし
こちら失礼になったわけでもないし
まずすごいな 気持ちいいんです
子供はやっぱり母親よく理解してくれる人だという
ものすごい愛情が生まれてくれるし
こちらは失礼を起こしてないんだから
向こう側はまあ次に失敗しないように気をつけるし
子供の場合は あ その場合はね
こうすれば失敗しないよと教えてあげればいいんだからね
包丁を取って怪我したならば
子供は包丁は持たないよ
包丁をどうしてもつかめたければ
こちらでこうやって握るんだよと言ってあげればいいんです
もし子供が包丁で怪我したったら
母親どうするんですか？なんであんたこんなことするんだ
ああだこうだとかね そこで旦那さんもお前が悪いんではないか
また怒られたり 病院に行ったらお医者さんにも怒られたり
なんで子供にそんなことを触らせるんですか？と
もうふったり蹴んだり状態でみんな間違ってるんです
怪我しちゃったら まあそれはそれなりに治療してあげて
あのもう包丁危ないよ
痛いでしょうとかね じゃあこれから気をつけましょうと
あるいはどうせ子供は大きくなるもんだから
包丁はこういう風につかめます
もういつでもじっと握っておきますよと
で 握らせてあげれば これぐらい硬くしなきゃダメだよと子供にできないぐらい筋肉と硬くしてあげちゃったら
子供はやっぱりこのワサビはやめましょうと自分で自発的にやめてくれるんです
ですから そういう風に面白く生きていられるんです
驚かないならばね それは社会的に
子供の世界で我々生きてるわけじゃないんだから
大人の世界だから 社会の中でも何が起ころうとも驚かないで
落ち着いて物事を見ていると
うまく人間関係をできるんです
私たちの悪いところは
自分も間違うのに 失敗だらけの人生なのに
他人から完璧さを求める
他人の過ちは許さない
腹が立つ 説教したくなる
それはもう単なる人間の間に爆弾をかけることと同じなんです
それは何の意味もないんです
いちいちいちいち もう終わりなく
もう喋るは喋るは 誰か失敗しちゃったら
1 日喋る 次の日も喋る
そこでまた人間関係がうまくいってほしいんだと自分で壊してるんだから
ですから もう楽しく明るくね
人の失敗を見たら別に驚かない
まあ当たり前だと 私から言うならば
人が人を殺すことも当たり前なんです
一人の人を 10人 20人殺したって
それまた当たり前なんです
ありえないことではないんです
ある人が頭狂っちゃって
もう1万人 10万人人でも殺そうと思うかもしれません
そういうのは世の中 そういうことさえ当たり前だからね
明日でも今日でも大地震が起きても
我々みんなパッと消えるかもしれませんし
何でも世の中であり得るものなんですね
もしもう 5時になっても来る
6時になっても 7時になっても太陽がそのまんまだったら驚いてください
9時になったんだけど
太陽はあっちそのまんまだったらもう驚く
本当に驚いてほしいんで
それ地球が止まっちゃった
1箇所で止まっちゃったら
それ以外はね あんまり驚くことは世の中でないんです
なんであれに驚くべきかというと
ありえない話だからね
ありえないことがあったら驚く
なぜならば それは人類の命に関わりますから
そうでないものには驚かないと
だいたいそれぐらいで結構
人間関係っていうのは
うまくいくだろうと思います
一旦そこら辺で一つのポイントとして
まあ 1時間は喋りましたけど
何時まで 5 そのまま続きますか
ん？ ちょっと質問していいですか
はい  あの 驚かないということってわかるんですけど
仏教は科学的だっていうふうに思えるんですけど
それから個っていうのはエゴですから
どうしても自分にがって
それは非常に堅実だと思うんですが
もう一つ 弱肉強食っていうのがございますですね
生物界っていうか 動物
生物界って生物の育て方なんですけど
動物生命というのは弱肉強食だと思うんです
ですから やっぱり人と付き合う中で
エゴの問題と もう一つ弱肉強食の視点というのはどういうふうに考えたらいいか
うん この弱肉強食のことも
このエゴの問題から出てくるんですね
エゴだから存在はいつでも弱肉強食ということになっているんですね
ですから 我々はその代わりに何か共存する方法はないかなと仏教は考えているんです
競争の代わりに共存の論理がないかなと
って考えているんですね
でも 理想的に共存の世界は成り立たないんです
できるだけ共存的な世界を作ろうと
っていうのは仏教のプラクティカル的な教えなんですね
実践的な教え 理想的な共存社会は成り立たない
なぜならば個は個は存在しているんだから
仮にでも ですから このそれから一つの論理は
この競争すると弱肉強食の同じことですけど
苦しみしか生まれてこないと
たまにでも共存すると
なんとなく気持ちいいと
幸福だと それだったらそちらの方ができるだけ増やそうというぐらいしか
その問題については答えがないんです
お釈迦様もそのことは何か考えて
もうもうもう全部僕も結構あるんです
ヨーロッパとか現代の社会は競争社会ですよね
人間の個の競争心を煽って
人たちを駆使しているというところがあるわけですね
公平の思想だと思うんですけど
それに対して仏教的な世界の思想は
競争社会は抑える方法があるんですか？ 抑えるというよりは
この競争社会っていうのは泥棒の社会だからね
現代ヨーロッパ的な経済っていうのは
人のものを盗んで自分で幸福をする
ただそれだけ 弱い者をいじめて
人のものを自分で盗んで食べているんですね
それで社会は発展しているごとく見えるんだけど
自分が自己で自己利己自得でもう破壊しちゃうんですね
お釈迦様は言うのは やがてあなた方は自分で自分たちを破壊するんだと
一時的にある人に金が合ってるように見える
ある国にお金が固まっているように見える
でもその国さえも幸福ではないし
その国が他の国々が貧しくなければ成り立たないんですね
ですから 人を不幸にして自分が幸福になるという経済論理は
仏教はどうかなと それはまあ良くないとは言わないんだけど
一応それは不戦たる道だと
商売の場合でも 私はこういうものは持っていて
でもこういうものは持ってないんだと
ですから お互いの 何て言いますか
コンプロマイズ お互いの理解のもとで
じゃあ交換しましょう
それで私も幸福で あなたも幸福ですよ
そういう経済なんです
ですから 物は売るのはいいんだけど
買った人は幸福にならなくちゃいけないんです
いわゆる現代と経済用語で言えば
この ...使用する人
何て言いますか 消費者
消費者があって欲しい品物は会社で作らなくちゃいけないんですね
今は逆なんですね 工場で勝手に自分勝手にものを作って
強引に売ってる 宣伝して買ってみたら
こんなもの要りませんと
使えないんだと たとえ電気炊飯器にしたっても
コンピューターついてるんだ
ああなってるんだ こうなってるんだと言うわ
言うわ 言うわ 誰一人その機能は使わないんです
まあ米洗っといて まあスイッチ入れるだけ
それだったらスイッチ１本でもうそういうのあってもあってもいいんだけどね
とにかくまあそれはそれでいいんだけど
あの工場の方が自分勝手に新しいものを作って作って
強引に売りさばいちゃうと
お客さんが完璧に喜ばないんです
それで摩擦が生まれてくる
宣伝しなくちゃいけない
宣伝するためにお金がかかる
そうするとまた値段が上がっちゃう
そうするとどうでもいいものを作るんだから
他の会社も同じことを作ってしまっちゃう
ライバルがさらに出来上がっちゃう
それでとことん 使用する人々を責め責められていじめられる
やがて購買力が消えちゃう
そうすると会社も倒産すると
その現象は毎日見えてくるんです
毎日 ですから そうじゃなくて
私は何か持っていて ものでもいいし
能力でもいいし 他人がそれを持ってない
その代わりに私は持ってないものをその人は持っていると言ったら
いかがでしょうかと あなたはこういうものを持っていて
私は持ってないんだけど
私はこういうものを持っていて
あなた持っていて どうですかと
交換的な立場で まあ交換原理はありますけど
これやっぱり得しようという原理がありますからね
交換の場合は相手から得しなくちゃいけないんですね
そこはちょっと良くないと
得することがなくて お互いに満足すればいいんじゃないかと
ということで ものの値段っていうのはある存在するものではなくて
人のこのニーズ ニーズって何でしょうかね
人がどれぐらいそれを要求しているかということによります
そういうふうな経済的な概念
まあいくつかあります
別に経済学という法はないんだけどね
いろいろ推測しなくちゃいけないしね
世の中このまま流れますからね
破壊するまではね そんな仏教的になるという見込みは全くないんです
それも驚かない  驚かない
驚かない 全然  逆に教職に驚かない
全然 まあそれは真理だから
驚いたってどうしますかね
そういうのは全然驚かない
だからもういろいろ生きる方法っていうのはその中から出てくるんです
驚かないんだから  それは慈悲っていうことと何か関係ある？ これからそれ喋ると思ってるんです
じゃあまあ一休みということで
これは次にまた部として始まります
じゃあ 3番目として この何があろうとも驚かないということから
我々は まあ人と付き合う方法を見つかります
それから次のポイント
私はわがままで個的な存在で
自分のために生きてるんだと
ということで 私は人から何か得をしようと思っちゃうと
その人は敵になるんだと
人と付き合いたいんだけど
いかがですか？あなたとあなた
私と仲良くすれば？と言ったら
その瞬間でその人は敵になっちゃう
また他の人と話してみたら
その人はまた敵になってしまっちゃうと
そういうことで 自己まあ個があって
個が自分のために行動しちゃうと敵ばっかし作る
一番いい例っていうのは
だいたい日本はどうかわかりませんだけど
いっぱい人々の共感を得て人気があって得る仕事はあるんですね
政治家みたい 政治家が大統領やら総理大臣やら国を天下取ったところで
結果はその人に限って敵だらけなんです
まあありとあらゆる警備
警備 警備 警備とか 国の選挙で国民の選挙で選ばれた大統領がどこかへ行くと
1週間  2週間前からその地方の全部警察からみんな調べる
大変なんです  私も何回もそういうひどい目に遭ってあって
もう絶対政治家のところに行かない
日本だったら別に問題ないんだけど
自分たちの国だったら
もう大統領なんか来ると言ったら
会うことになっちゃったら
まあ体中全部調べるわ
カバンの中はもう片っ端から見るわ
財布は開けてみるわ それお坊さんだからもう問題ないってこと知ってますけど
やっぱりそれでも決まってるんだから
もうやらなくちゃいけない
そこで車止まったら もう大体 500メートルぐらい遠く車止まらなくちゃいけない
それから歩いて行かなくちゃいけない
ああだこうだ この警備の厳しさ
たまに頭に来るんです
もう我々選んだやつは会うためになんでこんなという風にも
もう腹が立つんでしょうがないんですね
結局そこ同じ論理なんです
人の人気をあって選ばれたということは
その人はいろいろ甘い話をして
もうどう私にちょっと投票したらという話でしょ
それによってその人はいっぱい敵を作っただけなんです
今の自分の国の大統領はもう女の人なんですけど
まあこういう話をしたんですね
大統領になる前にはね
みんなとよく仲良くできたんだと
もう時間に関係なく みんなと一緒にご飯食べたり
もう誰ともよく喋る 大変優しい人でしたけど
今は一般の人と会う機会は全くないんだと
なんか全く別な世界で
別世界で隔離されて生活しなくちゃいけないと
これで政治できくはないんだと
一般の人の悩み苦しみに全然わからなくなっちゃったんで
もうもう隔離されちゃって
そんなもんなら敵になってしまっちゃうんです
ですから この子が自分のために人と付き合おうと思っちゃうと
その人が敵になっちゃうという論理はもう前に言いましたね
そこでこういうことをやってみたらいかがですかと
私は私の幸福を願っている
それはしょうがない 他人も他人の幸福を願っている
私は一時的に私の幸福をまあ一応置いておいて
他人にちょっとだけ幸福を与えたらどうですかと
この自分の中に入っているエネルギーを
ほんの少々でも外へ向いておく
それ英語でイントロエクストラという言葉が 2つあります
これ ちゃんとした日本語の言葉はありますけど
僕はあまり思い出せませんですけど
あの普通の世界で このイントロっていうのは
あまりこの自分の内に何か考える
自分のことを考える人
何て言いますか 内向 内向
内向性と言うんですね
それであまり内向性はいいと思ってないんです
普通でも心理学の世界でも
このエクストラというのはすごい社交的で
大体社交性ある人々はみんな人気があって
大変うまくいってるでしょ
で それは一般的だからあんまり意味がないんです
僕は言ってるのはもっとちょっと違う
私が言うのは 所詮人間が内向的なんです
全てみんな この心理学で言っているように
ある人が性格として内向的で
ある人が社交的でというのはじゃないんです
それはちょっと社会の上の上辺だけ見て言っていることで
なぜならば なんで社交的かというと
その方がその人は幸福を感じているんだから
ですから このイントロってのは内向的で
エクストラってのは社交的という意味で
であの 我々は我々の心の中から
ほんのちょっとだけでもいいんだから社交的になる
自分の幸福を考えることを置いておいて
まあちょっと人も助けてあげたってもいいんじゃないかと
それは強引にやらなくちゃいけない
自然的じゃないんです
覚えておいてください
例えば あの  2人がどこかへ遊びに行って
2人で2人 友達2人会して
じゃあ私は料理作ってきます
ある人はじゃあ私はご飯と
まああの味噌汁作ってきますから
じゃあ私はお菓子作ってきますよと
それで作っていたお互いに自分が二人分ご飯作って味噌汁作って
向こう側が二人分お菓子を使って
それでお互いにうまくいっちゃうでしょ
弁当分けて食べられる
そういうことでは 自分が 2倍ご飯炊くんだけど
人に一部あげる気持ちじゃないんですね
向こう側がお菓子持ってくるんだから
その代わりに半分分けるぐらいのだけであって
そうじゃなくて じゃあ二人どこかへ行こうと決める
じゃあそれだったら私は弁当二人分も作りますからと
あんたは楽に来てくださいと
というような形なんですね
いわゆるその考え方は
あんたも私は損するんじゃないか
その場合は と その人の弁当は
その人勝手に買ってくればいいんじゃないかということじゃなくて
これは論理的に言ってるの
この例出しても論理的に考えてください
人は幸福を求めている
今の場合は 昼ご飯 弁当を食べたがっているようなことで
じゃあそれちょっとしてあげればどうですかと
余計なお世話かもしれませんだけど
まあちょっとしてあげればどうですか
それは決して余計なお世話にならないんです
なぜならば どんな子も社会から幸福をちょうだい
幸福をちょうだいというふうに叫んでいるんだから
その中で一人がまあいいわ
少し余分に幸福を作ってあげますと
あなたに で 何かしてあげると
そういうふうに心のエネルギーは外に向かうと
ほんの少々強引にその向かう外に向かうたびにたびに
社会関係というのは何のことなくスムーズにいっちゃうんです
例えば 一人の人をそういうふうに助けてあげたと
助けてあげたならば 自分が見返りは求めてなし
見返り求めたらもう全く普通なことだから
普通な付き合いだから
見返りは求めていないし
助けてあげただけ そうすると
その人が自分の味方になるんです
敵ではなくて それしかないんです
今までいた人の付き合い方というのは
敵同士の付き合い方なんですね
お互いに利害関係で付き合ってるんだと
もうやむを得ず付き合ってるんだけど
本当は敵ですと ですから
夫婦っていうのは敵同士なんです
親子っていうのは敵同士なんです
もう悲しいことに お互いにいろいろ求めるものがある場合は一緒にいるんです
求めるのが消えちゃったら
もう敵同士で別れちゃうと
それじゃなくて 本当の味方ができちゃうんです
ですから うまく社会関係とか人間付き合うためには
自分でポジティブ的に行動的に見返りを求めないで
社会の中で行動する そうすると触れる触れる人が味方なんです
どんな人に触れても その人は味方です
すごい大雑把でわかりにくいんですね
これからちょっとわかりやすく
いろいろ例を出して考えてみましょう
一番わかりやすい例っていうのは
皆様ものすぐ感じるのは
いろんなことを人にしてあげたって
なんかその人はちょっとなんか悪いなと感じるでしょ
皆さんはそうでしょ もし隣の奥さんがいつでもいろいろ
もう大変高価なお菓子とかね
もう京都に行ったら京都のお菓子買ってくるわ
大阪に行って もう広島に行ったら広島のものを買ってくるわとかね
それまだ高価なものでも
自分が全然旅行はしないし
そうするとなんか立場が悪くなるんじゃないんですか？隣の奥さん
いつでもどこかへ旅に出ると
旅に出たらなんかお土産物を買ってくると
私は子供のことで忙しくて
全然もうスーパー以外にはどこにも行けませんと
というふうなことで なんとなく人のあれも受けたくなくなっちゃうような気持ちが生まれるんですね
それよく理解してください
それはもう普通なんです
なぜならば 人間の関係っていうのはギブアンドテイクの関係だからね
そうでなきゃうまくいかないんだから
そういうふうにきつく感じる
それは正しい それで我々は奥様の役をやってくださいと
隣の奥さんの役をやってください
今言ってるんです いわゆる余分に余分という言わないんだけど
人に人を助けてあげてください
人にいろんなことをしてあげてくださいと
そうすると 向こう側がすごくきつく
心の痛みを感じるんじゃないかなという問題が生まれてくる
そこはポイントなんです
ポイントっていうのは
もし私が誰かに何かをしてあげた
そうすると その人はやっぱりこの恩を返さなくちゃいけないなと感じたったら
私はいいことをしてないんです
あれ 単なる普通のギブアンドテイクの行為なんです
言う文句言うでしょ あの人に弔電を送ったのに
お礼以上も返ってこないんだとかね
なんだろうかと なんで腹立つんですかね
自分勝手に弔電送っちゃって
やっぱり弔電を送って向こう側喜んでくれると
こちら勝手に人の心のところまで計算して
向こうも知ってるんだから
まあ一応義理で送ったんだから
大変素晴らしい高価なものをありがとうございます
もうまあああだこうだとかね
そこまでしなくたってもいいのにとか
よく嘘ばっかりとかにやって生きてるんですね
嘘の塊でしょう そんなものは
まあそこで まあそういうことだから
我々は人に何かあげても
俺ぐらいはしろという見返りは求めちゃう
それで友達ができあがらないんです
ああ めんどくさいなという
という関係しか生まれてこないんですね
そこで我々は人に何かいいことをしてあげると
向こう側はなんのことなく
その恩恵を受けられるように
我々は落ち着いて 全く何のことなくしてあげなくちゃいけない
例えば まあわかりやすい例で
2人で弁当食べてるんだと
自分がちらっと見たら
やっぱり向こうの弁当よりはこちらの方が豪華ですよと
そうすると あ これどうですか？と言ったら
向こう側も何かこちらにくれなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうでしょ
で それではうまく そうじゃなくて
本当に これもう食べられないんだけど
こっちてもらってくれる？半分もらってくれる
助かりますよと こちらでお願いするような感じで
このこれ 今日はこの鶏肉の何て言いますか
作ってきたんだけど 本当もうあんまり多すぎて食べられないんだけど
ちょっともらっていただけますかと
助かりますよと 言ったら向こう側も遠慮するかもしれませんけど
どうぞどうぞ言ったら
ああ よかったよかったと自分で楽しめば
ああ 助かりましたと 言っちゃえば
向こうは何にもストレス感じないんです
自分の梅干しをあげなくちゃいけないと
そういうふうに自分が何かに人に何かしてあげるんじゃなくて
何て言いますか この場合
日本語でやらせていただいているんだと
そういうふうに行動すると
相手側は何のストレスも感じない
その代わりに本当に素晴らしい人だと
なんか優しい人やと それは頭で感じない
なんか波動がね 雰囲気がいいんですね
その人と一緒にいると
それで一人の人が味方になった
だから後で何かお願いしますとからくりやっちゃったらもうダメなんですけどね
今いろんな親切をしてくれるのは
後にもう 1年  2年後でなんかという状態ではないんです
ですから このうちに内向的な我々のエネルギーを人を助けてあげようとする
それで人が得するようにする
で エネルギーっていうのは入ったら返さなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 同じく私は人の弁当を食べたならば
私もいつかその人にそれなりの弁当を買ってあげなくたっても
他の何かをしてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると 私はその分払わない限り
こちらでこのツケですか
エネルギーとして残っちゃうんですね
あ なんとかしてあげなくちゃと
たとえ年賀状をもらっても
年賀状をもらったと 自分がその人に年賀状を出してないんだと
もう時期遅くなっちゃったんだと
時期も終わっちゃったと
言うと じゃあ来年出しますと思ったら
1年間も私はよくやりますけどね
で  1 年間もあのストレスを心の中に持たなくちゃいけないんです
ですから そういうことではダメと
ですから 我々は人に何かしてあげるんだけど
その人の心の中で あのマイナス的な
この払わなくちゃいけないという余分なエネルギーは溜まらないようにしてあげると
であの 見てください 皆様もご家族
ご家族を持ってますから
自分で経験があると思いますけど
この子供たちとかね 見ていると
知らない人が何かお菓子ではチョコレート一つでも
ポテトチップス一つでもあげたら子供は遠慮するでしょ
そこでお母さんの膝の上にポテトチップスの袋があると
子供は何のことなく手を出してパクパクと食べる
それでお母さんがやめなさい
やめなさいとぶん殴らなくちゃいけないんです
そこまで そこで子供は何のストレスも感じないんですね
まあ後で払わなくちゃいけないとかね
ああ ありがとうと 申し訳ないとかね
悪いですね とかね 恐縮ですねとか
そういう気持ちは何も感じない
やめなさいと言いながら
またお母さんのうちにもまた手を出して
また取って食べると それで子供は最高に幸福でしょ
なぜならば 母親が何も見返りを求めないであげてるんです
すごい気持ちがいいんですね
お互いに 子供が食べるとそれほど面白い幸福がないんですよ
自分の子供は 自分が一生懸命作ったものはむちゃくちゃ食べると
むさぼって食べるとすごい気持ちいいという幸福を感じると
そういうふうな感じで
幸福そこに我々の目の先に
鼻の先にありますから
それは他の人にでも微かな微かなことでも
まあ見返りなしにしてあげようと
向こうは悪いけど まあいいということ
まあどうせまあ私は余分なものだからね
助かったのはこちらですから
まあまあ気にしない 気にしないと
という風に言って 相手をリラックスしてあげる
それでなんかうまい人間関係
生まれて それはこの我々
みんな仲がいいと もう世界は兄弟やと手を繋いで首に手を出して踊っているような関係じゃないんです
別に なんとなく なんか空気のようにお互いにすごく
いい関係生まれてくるんです
それはいわゆる慈悲といえば慈悲の働きなんですね
慈悲はあくまでもこの自我という気持ちを
この気持ちを壊すんです
慈悲の瞑想によって 子という概念が破れちゃう
もしやがて子は消えて死んでしまったところで
素晴らしい慈悲も生まれてきて
そこで究極な幸福も生まれてくるんです
人間の中で生きている間は
解脱とはちょっと違いますけど
それはこの人間に味わえる最高の幸福の 2つあるんです
一つは心の幸福というわけです
それは慈悲から生まれるんです
心の安らぎ 幸福は慈悲の瞑想を完成したら出てくるんです
それは生きている間 また死んじゃったらそれ忘れるかもしれませんね
それで智慧の幸福があるんです
また ヴィパッサナー的な瞑想なんかして智慧を得たならば
心は完全に綺麗になったならば悟れるんです
それで最終的な幸福も得られるんです
ですから 仏教では生きている間は
我々は慈悲の瞑想によって幸福を味わって究極的な
それでさらに修行して
煩悩をなくし 悟りも得るという 2つの目的を考えているんです
そういうことで 今人間関係のことだけ喋ってますから
人間の間で私たちは慈悲の心を持ち続けると
子ということ 自分のことにもう気が回らないんです
自分のこと 自分のことということを心配しなくなって
まあみんな幸福であればそれでいいんじゃないかと
これはすごい立派な人間になるんです
想像でできないことまでできるようになってくるんです
そうすると 何の問題なく
あんまりにも美しい人間関係が生まれてくる
友達だ 友達だとか たくさん友達でも迷惑でしょ
電話かけなくちゃいけない
手紙書けなくちゃいけない
いろいろお土産送らなくちゃいけない
ああだこうだとか考えてみてください
みんないっぱい人間関係できればいいと思っちゃいますけど
100人  200人ぐらい友達がいたならば
自分の誕生日にも誰が呼ぶかと
大変危なくてしょうがないでしょうに
10人しか呼べないんだと
それで 10人が呼んだと
呼んだんだ でも自分には 100人ぐらい友達がいるんだと
その人々に知られたらどうするんですか？ですから
そんなこの人間ともなれなれ仲良く
もう何人とも付き合うということは
これはえらい迷惑なんです
やりきれないんです そういう人間関係じゃないんです
それは大変な迷惑なんです
できるだけ自分にコントロールできるぐらいの人々と具体的に付き合えばいいし
それと違って我々は人を助けてあげると
見返りを求めていないと
で そうすると なんか言葉でちょっと言いにくいんだけど
なんかすごい素晴らしく
どんな人とでもなんとなく喋る
なんとなくお互いにやり取りする
だからといってお互いにストレスは感じない
もし住所でも交換したならば
もし何か後で思い出したら電話して
ああ そうです この間の人
ああ よかったよかったとかね
そういう風になるような
美しいレベルが高い人間関係が生まれてくるんです
そこはもう強引にやらなきゃ自然に続いてこない
慈悲の行動は それはどうやってやりますかと
この強引にやるときでも
こういう風に実況してみたらどうですか？例えば皆様方は会社で仕事をする
会社で仕事をするとよく腹が立つんですね
あれ 何でしょうかと 自分がした仕事を褒めてほしいんですね
ちゃんと褒めて評価してもらわないと機嫌が悪い
それでトラブルを起こしちゃうんです
それは当たり前で みんな自分のためにやってるんだから
褒めてもらったら自己が喜ぶんです
向こう側もそれなりに忙しい子だから
褒めるぐらい知恵が回るかどうか分からないし
めんどくさい 一つ一つ褒め褒めまくっていくと
本人も個人だからもう褒めませんね
褒めてくれません それでどんな会社でもお互いに仲が悪くなっちゃうんです
仲 それじゃなくて 私は会社に行く
それでできるだけ立派に仕事をすると
私に任せた仕事は 私は徹底的にやると
それは上司に認めても認めなくても
上司がその日は休みを取って来ていても
来てこなくても 私がやった仕事は
隣の人は自分がやったように上司に告げても告げなくても関係ないんだと
私はこの会社から給料をもらってるんだから
今日 1 日の給料分をいっぱいこの仕事をしてやりました
ああ 良かったと 今日 1 日は
今日 1 日は正直に生きてられるんだと
今日 1 日の食べるご飯は全くつけではないんだと
ちゃんと真面目に仕事をしたんだからと
ですから かすかにでも褒めてほしい
認めてほしいという気持ちは消す
それ消せない場合はもうちょっと威張ってください
あなた方なんかに認めてくれなくてもいいんだと
私は私に正直に生きてるんだと
そういうふうに威張ったらやりやすいかもしれません
で 上司があなた昨日本当に素晴らしい仕事をしました
だからとありがとうございますとか
そんなことなく まあまあまあだからまあただの仕事でしょうと言われた方が
上司に対しても気持ちいいんです
もうなんかね あのグルグル挨拶回るわ
体曲がるわ曲がるわ ヘビみたいですけどね
そこまで負けて負けて礼をしちゃうと
向こう側もそれ分ストレスかかっちゃうんですね
ですから 自分が完璧に仕事をしましたと
それで認めてほしいかどうかもう気持ちがなかったと
上司が認めて褒めたっても
まあまあまあそんなことはまあまあ
どうせ私の仕事だからなあということで
そういうふうにお互いにリラックスさせるように
相手にストレスかからないようにやることと
で 会社でもそれは私が今言ってるイントロバートイントロバートの内向的な子が社交的になることなんです
日本では人を助けようと思ったって
なかなか助けて欲しがってる人はいませんだから
それはちょっと難しいかもしれません
でも 自分に毎日行ってる会社でそれできる
そこで奥様方は料理をする
旦那が怒ると遅れてくる
それで腹が立って腹が立って
せっかく作った美味しいものはもう冷めちゃって
もう食べられなくなっちゃったと
一体この人は何時に来るんですかと
自分がこれ美味しく食べて褒めてほしいという気持ちがあるんだから
その気持ちが生まれてくる
ですから そういう気持ちじゃなくて
とにかく立派に美味しく料理を作るんだと
で それで自分の仕事は終わったと
そうすると向こう側もやっぱりあれほど一生懸命作ってるんだから
やっぱり美味しく食べなくちゃいけないと思って食べてくれるんです
いちいち今日は今日の料理はどうどうどうとかね
いちいちしつこく聞く必要はないんです
その場合は褒めてほしいという人間の弱みがそこにあるんですね
褒めてほしいのは普通なんです
なぜならば自己はやるんだから
それで敵が出来上がっちゃうんですね
かえって だからそれはやめましょうと
内向的じゃなくて 社交的に
ちょっとほんのちょっとほんのちょっとやってみようと
電車で座席を人にあげると
なんか椅子を許してあげちゃったら
なんか弱い人はなんか座りたがらないんですね
あげ方まずいんです 私があげちゃったら確実に座るんです
なぜかというと 例えばちょっと弱い弱いような人が来ちゃったら
向こうは座っていたならば
なんかサッと立って なんか嫌な人が来たような感じで
ちょっとそこちょっと他のところに行くんですね
ほんのちょっと行ったら向こう側から見れば
あ 座席が空いてるんじゃないか
私も体も弱くて座れると
人から許してもらったってことさっぱりわからない
さっぱりわからない 大体そういうところでもこの行動できるんです
そういうふうに人助けをするもんなんです
特別に何かするということよりは
毎日我々やっていることの人の関係だから
料理作ることも人間関係で
お風呂を入れることも人間関係で
お化粧することも人間関係で
すべて人間関係でしょうに
ですから 毎日のことを自己のためではなくて
例えば女性の方々はお化粧する
全部自己を膨張したいと思ってやっているんだから
結局結果としては まあ私は平気で言いますけど
あんまりもう最高得点は得られませんよ
自分好き勝手に自分の好みでお化粧したっても
自分だけで見たければ
自分の部屋の鍵をかけて
もうやりたい放題やってもいいんだけど
これもう迷惑じゃん 外へ出るんですね
で 外へ出るならば 人が見てどういうふうにその人が気持ちよくなるかということで
お化粧のシステムを変えれば
まあもっと違うかもしれません
その時の人にどう見られるか
どう見られるかと思ったら
自分のことなんですね
そういうことでもなくて
そこら辺はね まあいくらこんな
例えば豪華な指輪を持ってるんだと
まあいくら豪華でなくても
そんなことをはめても
そこいいんじゃったらまあいいわ
そんな安いものをはめていくんだと
そういうふうな感じで
この自分が自分のためにお化粧するんじゃなくて
もう社会でみんなそのそれなりに気持ちよく
明るく もう違和感なくいれるためのものだと
というふうに そのお化粧でもそのふうにできるんですよ
人の助けになるように
何でもできるんです なぜなら
我々は何でも自分のためにやる
その自分のためにやることは
もうちょっと変えて立場を変えてみる
同じこと それから我々にやっているすべてが人間の付き合い
人間関係なんですね 人間関係でなくやるものは何でしょうかね
たとえご飯食べる時でも
いろいろね みんなと一緒に食べるんだから
それも人間関係なんですね
ですから ご飯食べると自分
自分が好き勝手に食べても全くかえっていけないでしょうに
日本でよくやりますよ
指を舐めたりとかね 外国人から見れば
まあ結構失礼な態度なんですけどね
まあ一応日本には日本なりのしきたりありますけど
まあそれは自分勝手に破るわけじゃなくて
ちゃんといい雰囲気を作って食べるとか
食べることさえ人間関係なんです
そういうことで 我々にとってはこの内向的な自分を少々社交的な自分に入れ替える
入れ替えると 特別に友達と友達の首クラスが大きくなるということはなくて
人間の関係がすごく素晴らしく
トラブルない コンフリクトない
ぶつかり合うことなくうまくいっちゃうんです
うまく社会に溶け込んでうまくいっちゃうんです
で もっとまた理解するために必要なんですけど
何でしたっけ？これは慈悲という言葉で理解してもいいし
で もう一つ理解する方法はあるんです
この私はわがままですが
私はわがままは大嫌いでしょ
大体世の中って私はわがままです
でも この人々は本当にわがままで嫌な人だなと
大体世の中そんなもんなんです
だからいい人間関係は生まれてこない
自分がわがまま でも人はあまりにもわがままになっちゃうと
あんたあまりにもわがままだから
あなたとは付き合うことはできませんと
これからあなたとは商売はできませんと
あなたの会社はあまりにも自分の利益でばっかり考えているんだから
その会社とはもうやり取りしませんとか
会社にしたってもわがままだったら嫌だと
個人個人の場合でも わがままな人とは付き合いたくないという立場があるんですね
それは合理的に言えばこういう論理なんですね
私はわがままですが 人のわがままは絶対許せませんとか
私はわがままですが わがままな人は大嫌いですよと
あるいは他の言葉で言えば
私はわがままですが 世の中の人間は絶対わがままになってはいけませんと
私のためにと そういう考え方で生きているんです
この人間がなんとなくこの人間が生きてますけど
自分が生きている哲学はわからないんですね
お釈迦様はこの哲学を教えてくれる
あなたの哲学はそういう哲学だよと教えてくれたら腹が立ちますけども
なんと失礼なことですか
でも真実なんですね それでこの人は立派になってしまうんです
そういうことで 私はわがままですし
で 私は客観的に人のわがままを見ると
ものすごい気持ち悪いし
それだったら自分が超気持ち悪い人間だと
他の人から見ればわがままでしょ
超気持ち悪いです だから自分がもう散々嫌われているんだと
たとえ微かなアポイントにしたっても
自分が何か用事があって
向こうに電話して用事がありますけども
明日 2時はどうですかと
そしたら向こうはあの 2時と言ったって 2
時半だったら時間ありますけどと
あの 実はですね 私は 2時半に何とか何とか買い物に行かなくちゃいけないんだけど
2時だったら本当に便利ですけど
別にあんた何もこのごろ何もやってないでしょ
ですから 2時はもう会いましょうよと言ったら
向こう側はこちらの合意の 2時に会うんですね
友達同士だったらそんなことないかもしれませんね
それくらいでもこちらのわがままなんですね
で 向こう側がなんとなくかすかにまあ嫌だなと
ああ しょうがない 意地に会ってあげなくちゃいけないとなっちゃうんですね
そういうふうなことで
我々はいつでもこの人のわがままで結構痛い目に遭ってるんです
これ毎日遭ってるんです
自分も自分がわがままで
みんなに嫌な気持ちをしているんです
ですから これは怖いと感じる
わがままな自分が醜いんだと
わがままな自分が嫌われるんだと
わがままな自分が損をするんだと
自分がわがままだから人間関係がうまくいかないんだと
ですから 自分のことを置いておいて
かすかにでも人のことを考えましょうと
っていうふうなことでも
一つの方法 手段なんですね
この手段の場合は このわがままは嫌われると覚えておくんですね
わがままは嫌われる 不幸の元であると覚えておけば
もうなんとなく自分の心からわがままは消えていっちゃう
それで人のわがままを見ると
あんたわがままではないかと子供に言う必要もないんです
その時瞬間に 私はわがままで
自分の意の通りに子供は行動して欲しかった
子供はそうはやってないんだから
私は子供をわがままだと思ってるんだと理解すればうまくいくんです
会社で散々仕事をさせちゃうと
自分は休みを取りたいんだと
そうするともう会社の社長やら部長やら上司やら
すごいわがままで 自分のことしか考えなくて
自分はいつでも仕事に呼ばれるんだと
そんなことで考えるんじゃなくて
自分が休みたい わがままだから
それでもう会社の人は会社のために私を呼びたいと
だから私は腹が立ったんだ
私のわがままだから腹が立ったんだと理解しておけば
そこで問題は解決する
こういうふうな方法で
一応人間関係はなんとか出来上がるだろうと思います
この慈悲と慈悲喜捨と４つの立場がありますけどね
慈っていうのは友情で
悲は悲しむ 悩んでいる人々を助けてあげることで
喜っていうのは人の喜びを自分でも喜ぶことで
捨っていうのは何ものがあっても驚かないような気持ちなんですね
何でもありきと認める心で
ですから 慈悲喜捨なんです
で それは適当に実行すると
毎日幸福になっていくんですね
それからこの仕事をしたり
いろんなことをすると
私たちはこの仕事自体は楽しむと褒めてもらいたいという
この後の話じゃなくて
言葉で言えばこういうことには結果楽しむんじゃなくて
過程を楽しむと 仕事をする
それで結果を楽しむという人は
いい仕事をして もう会社にいっぱい儲かって儲けてあげて
会社から表彰状をもらおうと思っちゃうと
で そこで苦しみが生まれてくるんですね
もし他の人がもっといい仕事をしたならば
その人表彰状もらっちゃいますから
で 悔しくてしょうがないんですね
自分が苦労して仕事をしたのに
で 不幸になってしまっちゃう
相手がライバルになってしまうんです
そういうことで 誰が表彰状をもらっても
それは関係ないんだと 10
人で仕事をするならば
一番点数高いのは誰であろうと
それは関係ないんだと
私はその仕事を楽しんで充実してやりますと
言って過程を楽しむ 結果ではなくて
結果はあまり気にしない
ちょっと失礼な言葉なんですけど
まあ結果についてそんなにこだわらないんだと
その過程を楽しむということも
また一つ大変いいありがたいことなんです
人間まあ結果を見て褒めてもらいたいんだからね
ですから 慈悲のことを実践すると
ただ単に人に優しくしてあげることだけ楽しむ
悩んでいる人にそれなりに助けてあげる
相談に乗ってあげる それだけ楽しむ
例えば人が悩み事を言ってくれたと
こちらはもうなんとか相談してあげて
それからこの後ですかと
ああだこうだ ああだといろいろ聞くでしょ
これからどうです？どうなったんですか？とかね
よかったでしょうねとかね
僕はあんまりあの言葉嫌いんですね
あ その間本当に良かった
良かったとかね これ良かったですね
良かったですね これ強引にその人を責めることなんです
その人 本当に感謝したがってるかないか分かりませんだから
失礼なんです まあたとえ私が人に何か教えてあげる
それで第三者が待っている
あ ちゃんと質問に答えてもらってよかったですね
よかったですねとか言うと
その人の態度を強引に責めることなんです
本当に良かったかないか
その本人の問題だから
そこでそうですねと嫌で言わなくちゃいけない場合はどうするんですかね
よかったよかった なんでよかったですね
よかったですねとか 自分で暗示かけてあげるんですかね
よくやるでしょ 普通だったら
よかったんだったら本人のことだから
本人知ってるはずでしょうに
関係ない人々 一生懸命暗示かけるんですよ
よかったですね よかったですねと
あれ すごい失礼だなと思いますよ
ですから とにかく我々は
この人からよかったとかなんとかということを言われる
それも失礼になっちゃうし
人を助けてあげる ただ質問されたら答える
ちょっと悩み事があって
それを打ち明けたら それはちゃんと聞いてあげると
で よかったかないかっていうのは
それはその人の問題で
自分が過程だけ楽しむ
いい仕事をしようではないかと
人の悩み事をやっぱり真剣に聞いてあげましょうと
その過程だけ楽しんで
それで終わると 自力者の実行はできるんです
でも と また喋るんだったら
次のポイントには行きます
あ